il y a des choses qu'il faut qu'il faut
préciser sur
la création de de prison vous vous me
dites mais plus on en construit plus on
les remplit bon alors moi je vais vous
dire je suis assez dubitatif mais
aujourd'hui on a
[Applaudissements]
73000 détenus
pour pardon pour 60 60 un peu plus de
60000 places
donc il y a pas 50 solutions où on
libère
plus de 10000 détenus
ouais mais il faut en assumer la
responsabilité des détenus qui ont été
envoyés en prison par des magistrats
dans le cadre de leur liberté
juridictionnelle bon
je suis pas certain que ça fasse pas une
révolution dans ce pays
parce que un moment
on n'a pas 50000 solutions où on
construit des prisons et si on construit
on va au bout du programme alors il y a
la moitié des établissements
pénitentiaires qui seront sortis de
terre et opérationnelles l'année
prochaine j'inaugure 10 établissements
pénitenciers en cours d'ici la fin de
l'année 2024 on aura la moitié mais où
on construit plus de place de prison et
puis alors il y a plus de questions de
surpopulation carcérale où on prend la
responsabilité faites-moi cette
proposition de libérer 12000 détenus
dans ce pays parce que je rappelle que
quand Nicole Belloubet et elle a eu
raison de le faire à libérer des détenus
parce que il était dangereux dans la
promiscuité carcérale on était en pleine
pandémie vous avez vu les polémiques on
en parle encore aujourd'hui donc il y a
aussi ah non mais pardon il y a il y a
aussi ces équilibres si vous voulez
parce que l'extrême droite va s'emparer
de ça pour vous dire les choses de façon
cash
mais oui mais mais monsieur monsieur le
sénateur vous avez exprimé votre idée
là-dessus qui me soit permis d'exprimer
la mienne maintenant résumé cette
question de la surpopulation carcérale à
la construction d'établissements
pénitentiaire ça n'est pas vrai parce
que dans le texte d'ailleurs que je
soumets à votre appréciation on essaie
d'obtenir davantage de place de travail
d'intérêt général